And then, and then Minneapolis shoot my special.
I did my show last night at the Hollywood improv. And, um,
I did my hour and I'm very excited about it. And, uh, and I,
I F I didn't do it in maybe like a month.
And I finally did it now that I'm done with this movie, uh, I'm able to do,
I'm able to get the reps in and do my, and do my set, uh, uh,
before I shoot it. And, uh,
I did it last night and I went and when Varo and I'm very excited and I got
rejuvenated. Have you ever been rejuvenated? It feels good, man.
Um, one time with one of my exes, she would be like, she would be like,
let me, let me get a kiss. And then I kiss her and then like a golden one.
And then she would be like, Oh, I'm rejuvenated. And that's cute.
And that's just a cute story for you, dude. Was it my ex-wife? Yes.
Did we get divorced? Yes. Am I at divorce? Yes. Is it weird to think of that?
About yourself? Yes. Even at such a young age. I'm 39. Yeah, it's weird,
but that's it, dude. It's all good, man. This is real life.
And if you're divorced out there, Cole
divorce has a negative connotation. It's the to be divorced. Do it.
It really is. It really is.
You ain't until you're married once and you divorced.
Cause then you know what the life is all about, man. You know what life is?
When you get divorced, dude, you know what marriage is?
You don't know what it is, how come you never know what is until it's over.
You don't, you don't know. You ever see a movie. And you're like, Whoa,
that movie reps. And then a week later, you're like, I don't really remember it.
It's because you, you didn't know what it was until afterwards, baby.
I know what it is now, dude, what if I was saying that?
And just tears were streaming down my face. Um, so yeah. Yeah,
dude,
but life continues to rip,
right? It does. Life happens. Okay.
Now that's something that would just be on a stupid coffee mug that a girl would
post on Instagram with quote unquote, messy hair and quote unquote,
no makeup with her eyes rolled up to the side.
Just like Mondays. That would be the caption.
And it would say life happens in some kind of squiggly writing with like
a stupid border around it, on the coffee. Now would that be? Yeah,
that would be, that would exist. Life happens.
But what we have to remember is once you past
this situation, rejuvenation, babies,
and life rips again,
life rips again. Now could that also be the title of the show? Yes. Well,
I forget it. Yes, but life rips again, dude.
And that's why I put these life's life rips hoodies,
and t-shirts out there that you can get to support this podcast.
So we keep eating. So we came Pete and dude,
you want to get a, you want to,
you want to get some merch so I can keep eating these Turkey sandwiches.
You click the buy, you click the purchase,
uh, icon on my website. And it's like,
I'm practically going nom, nom, nom. That's it.
You're clicking the maiden.
So.
You click it. And when you click buy or purchase and you click,
you know, next day air or whatever the it is when you click that,
I want you to imagine me going nom, nom.
This cult.
Leader, is serious business dude.
And I, and I said, I wouldn't say his name. And I'm never going to say,
I would never say his name on this podcast. But Jared Leto is not a cult leader.
That's a celebrity dude, me cult leader.
The guys walking.
Around with robes and. He turned me off a robes, man.
He turned me off a robes dude. I was going to wear all white and this dude,
Jared Leto. And I don't even, I'm not going to say I don't say his name,
but dude, the fact that that dude is walking around in white robes,
like what this boy was going to do, dude, the youngest men alive me.
I was going to make this call and this dude walks around,
but he's serious about it.
You know what it's like.
Dude. It's like when Tupac had the in a here's what?
Another reason why I'm just like Tupac dude. It's like when Tupac had the,
uh, he,
he was like obsessed with death and he wanted to make the album with the death
and and death around the corner and. That's when,
and then biggie came out with ready to die. And Tupac was like, what the?
I was the one that told you I was going to do all the deaths.
And the biggie was like, I don't give a.
He did ready to die with a baby on the cover. Right?
Dude, Jared little dome biggie me.
I don't, I don't say his name on this podcast, but don't biggie me. Oh,
by the way, if you're watching on the video podcast, just so you know,
I'm serious. I got a thick chain.
I have a thick chain on serious.
Business. Dude. I have a thick chain on, I had.
A thin chain.
But I had to level up dude, cause there's guys out there like Jeremy,
[inaudible] floating around and I'm not going to say his name,
but he's floating around in a robe with a bunch of like fives. By the way,
you see the people that are in his cult fives,
maybe a six is in there somewhere. But dude us, we got tens, man.
Everyone's killing it. They're all doing fitness.
The guys are prettier than the girls in our. By the way,
guys walk around all like the Persian guy in 300, just like,
what would you like to today? Those are my dudes.
Those are my dudes.
And we're all in sucking and getting that hedonistic lifestyle.
And we're sitting in the installing the tall grass and I cannot believe I am
right now saying all this stuff with two other guys in this room,
just straight faced doing their own. I haven't get rid of.
And one fire are literally staring at their computers like this emoji,
the emoji with the straight eyes and the straight mouth and I'm being.
Cause they,
you know why because I'm being serious because this isn't a laughing matter.
Dude. I have a, if I take this shirt off and keep the chain on,
I swear to God, I I've done it and walked around and people literally,
and I'm not joking. They mistake me for DMX. They go like, this is that.
Oh nevermind. And I know what they're thinking.
They're thinking is the lawnmower right next to the tray,
The Lamar right next to the tree. My favorite thing about DMX is this.
The melody will be like, dang DNA, DNA,
DNA, DNA, DNA, DNA. That'd be like the melodic tune of the thing.
And the DMX will just straight up, come on and he will go. Dang, dang, dang,
dang, dang, dang, dang, Danny like, Hey dude,
there's some different they're covering that part. I swear to God.
One of the melodies is
[inaudible] and it'll be like, you could be blind and
[inaudible] what's that DMX.
I got to do it from my phone because we're doing it because I don't have sound
on the thing, but we're going to do it, do it, try it. I'll give it to you,
give you the computer. Okay. And while I do it like this,
I'll do it on the thing. But this is what DMX di does you think?
I'm not who we be is the one first who we be DMX.
First thing that comes up, of course, here we go.
Busting a nut.
Oh wow. Busing. And I never realized in the beginning of the song, he goes,
Oh yeah. Another one of those.
What? Doesn't work. It'll still. Yeah. Okay. Well
I can't do it because it's going to.
Whatever, dude, I can't do it because it's going to flag it.
It's going to flag the thing.
And then we're not going to be able to monetize it for YouTube.
Like people are like, people are coming to congratulations. Podcasts to listen,
to who we be from DMX on my phone.
That's not even connected to the source.
Like somebody wants to hear me going like, Oh, he's busting a nut over DMX.
Who we be by the way, you know, who's doing that.
Who's listening to who we be.
Anyway. You got it. I worked on fire. Seems to think it's working now.
So we're putting it back on, dude. See, this is it, man.
I'd get you like the rawness dude. Let's see if it works.
It's not working all good,
but you mean it's coming something from the motherboard,
which means it's one fire's fault.
Which means obviously he's not changing his name anytime soon.
So DMX will do that. And uh,
and I'm practically DMX is basically what I'm saying, dude. Cause I got a chain.
I wanted to one day be the shirts off comic.
This is way before Burt Chrysler and now I'm like, okay, well Bert does it.
So I want it to be the jaw rule of comedy is basically what it was,
but now Burt does it and I can't do it. And that's fine. I'm happy for Burt.
Honestly. I think he's got like a million followers on the Instagram,
so that's great. Um, it works now.
It works now dude, it works now, man.
It works now. And just so you know, it worked just to prove it works right now.
Yup.
Hell yeah, dude. Let's get these in. Uh,
let's put these in because I meant to do those from earlier and thrown a little
one of these because I'm going to do it from earlier.
And then I also meant to do one of these a little bit earlier when I was talking
about Tupac.
So rude. I'm so rude.
I wrote a song like that,
but life rips and it continues to rip and that's it.